hey GQ I'm kasam Brailsford I'm a
professional choreographer and dancer
today we were gonna be watching some
famous dance clips this is the breakdown
[Music]
this scene is from the greatest showman
I'm actually in this scene and I'm
wearing a long white wig this scene took
a long time to film it was really cool
but we were restricted to this circular
rink I just remember filming this scene
so many times because it was such a
important part of the movie we like did
it for the cranes we did it for the
study Cavs we did it for all the side
cams
we definitely danced this one a lot I
guess the bigger the cast the more room
for error
right so it's like when we're rehearsing
and all that all that stuff to get it
clean it's just part of the more people
you add on and trying to look all alike
it just gets hard that was something one
of the challenges and always doing it
the same so that when you're cutting and
back and forth you're in the same spot
you're doing the same things that's a
challenge too because you also don't
have marks and this is a musical so we
had to sing along the entire time so you
were singing we're dancing and trying
not to fall on sawdust as well
positive so this part right now where
we're all slowing down we all had to do
this one by one on a green screen so
right now we're not all together like
they did this in post so we all had to
do our jump on a green screen so they
could film it in slow motion
so that they can slow it down for this
so that it looks like she's in one place
and we're all going super so and after
doing green screen they can slow it down
you put it all together and you get what
you see right here I wish I could jump
that high for that long but it's not
reality Samia also one other part that
was really hard for this is this was
made up to the words a lot of times you
learn choreography to lyrics and then
because of that when you're changing
those lyrics you're like something that
you're bringing nested like unadjusted
I'm saying marching on marching on
that's what I learned it too but then
I'm like singing oh-oh-oh and it's not
what I'm doing so it's like your brain
is used to singing something that you're
doing but then you're singing something
else and it's all very confusing we
drilled it so many times and recorded it
so many times that it's like ingrained
in my body I can completely do this from
head to toe this is breaking I've seen
this a very long time ago probably like
when I first started dancing this is
break dancing I cannot break dance and
I've always wish I could because of
movies like this this guy has like so
much control he's just hitting
everything in the music he's hitting
every single beat with a different part
of his body with break dancers a lot of
times it's just a lot of just like three
selling they're just dancing they're
letting the music take over so it's not
necessarily like training per se it's
just always practicing always
freestyling just getting out there and
honing in your own there's no like right
or wrong it's just however you're
feeling the music cover you want to hit
the music there's certain moves and
there's certain tricks that people do
all the same but then there's a lot of
stuff that you can do on your own
pauses I do love this but you can
totally see the string they didn't have
as good of effects when this movie first
came out
pause before he was moonwalking that was
gliding which is a also a term for this
move where you're like going heel toe
and you're going sideways it's very
similar but gliding is when it's
sideways and then moonwalk is backwards
they're both very hard to make really
smooth and he's doing a damn good job at
both of them this is probably one of the
greatest examples of breakdancing I mean
no Michael Jackson but still save the
last dance
[Music]
pauses what she try to get a Juilliard
you're not getting into Juilliard doing
a ballet hip-hop this is just bad
hip-hop
[Music]
vanya this is a hundred percent a double
this part right here it's from the back
the technique
yeah that's def 100% a double at that
moment look at her key and look at her
arms and look at her posture right now
this is her when it's in the back she's
super pulled up her legs are straight
her feet are pointed there you see that
position her feet are pointed her arms
about her neck is elongated and when it
goes to the front of her it's not this
at all now you see now she has biscuits
biscuits are when like you don't really
point your feet all the way through your
toe and I don't really have the best
feet so I I feel for her you know oh no
why yeah and after that tear it's the
nose it's like the typical like what you
want hip-hop to be but she off see
actually does an up brought which is a
breakdancing move which is starts right
here that's called it up rock it's like
where you go it's like you cross and you
go down and she's just adding missing to
her ballet solo because that's what you
do and say the last and it's still not
great but I mean it's still her which is
cool they only use him to double a
couple times you can tell when it's
there and when it's her and this is all
still her I just love the typical dance
Billy where they come out and there's a
ballerina they do hip hop and then she's
gonna convince these judges and now
they're into and are nodding their heads
and you know Reed it's just like the
typical the typical story now sexy
dancing okay here we go
all these legs are double you can tell
if you're really trying to portray like
good technique especially like with
ballet I think if the actress or actor
can do it than you she's a double so
that you're not showing the world wrong
technique so I think a double is very
necessary sometimes doubles aren't just
because they're bad at dancing it's
because something happened you don't
know the shooting schedule or how many
times they did it they work really hard
and a lot of times they're and they're
standing in for them like the double duo
first for lighting and like they'll
double be there in rehearsals with us
and then the double go teach them so
they're doing double duty a lot of times
I give it a see cuz it wasn't a I mean
it was bad but there was effort I know I
know I know you got served
they're killing it like they're really
killing it they're so together I just
remember watching this when it first
came out and it was a lot of dancers I
looked up to when I was younger and it
just showed dancing in such a cool way
dance battles are very real they're not
just a movie thing they're very real if
you go out to a club and like songs come
on it's just like natural dancers we
want to move and you're getting a cirque
where you start dancing not necessarily
always a battle but the dance circle you
know I've never personally been in a
battle also this isn't realistic I don't
want to compare it to like white chicks
in other movies they're not gonna go out
and then with five friends and all know
the same thing and be there right that
when it's a competition yes that makes
sense they're our crews and then they
all they do compete with each other and
they do all know the same routine but
like you're never just gonna go out and
bust into this yeah I'd be like hey yeah
let's break into like routine number
five it's just not realistic cause this
is more realistic say you're out and
about and dancers their music comes on
one person's doing something everyone's
cheering him on like his friends are
showing him all the other people are
cheering them on this it happens you
don't really break into like a group
routine it's more like solo stuff okay
rewind this sir now look at this move
done right and not on Julia Stiles so
this is the same move that she just did
in the last movie play there we go you
see that it literally is the same move
but it looks good now this is a good
example of like good hip-hop and
contrasting between this and save the
last dance they're just more in the
pocket
in the pockets a dance term where it's
like you say what you're really riding
the beat it's like you're not early
you're not late but you're just in the
pocket but they just have a groove about
it and it's not super stiff I think
that's another thing with her it's super
stiff with them they're just like you
feel it you feel the music like they're
actually telling a story they're
actually there with the music and
they're not too sharp and robotic yeah I
think also with Julia style she's an
actress and she's learning to dance for
a movie she's doing her what she was
taught you know but that's not her first
thing I'm sure if all these dancers
going act we're gonna be like oh these
are dancers that are trying to act
silver linings playbook
[Music]
pause I love this just cuz they're like
having fun right and I think that's why
people relate to it cuz it's like at a
wedding everyone's gonna get up and
dance that's kind of like this and also
doing whatever the music tells you and
how the music moves you is very
different and it doesn't always have to
be ballet or hip-hop or technically
correct you can just literally do
whatever you're feeling and it's still
dancing sometimes they don't need to
train a lot if you don't need to be
technically correct so it's like it can
vary and then they're really busy too if
they're shooting this movie so you only
have so much time you're lucky if you
get multiple days with them I am curious
to see how they got out of this lift
because they cut so I'm wondering like
how graceful ungraceful was this
dismount after hit right before she
comes out cuz she's up there and then
they cut and all of it her hands are on
the ground this isn't an easy thing to
get out of so it's like if you're not a
dancer she just like put her hands on
the ground and the kick her feet over so
that she doesn't like come straight down
on her head and back to ballroom again I
mean it's not technically great but
they're in it here we go what are they
getting up for the big lift Oh get it
get it Jim
elbows also it's like so inspired by
Dirty Dancing that part let's rewind and
figure out what exactly went wrong with
that lip he get his arms extended when
you when you don't lock your arms it's
so much harder so you want to use the
momentum of them coming to you and lift
it up straight as they get there so
everything goes this is so much harder
to hold weight on then straight arms and
right now his arms are bent so he can't
get her as high as he wants and then so
she's trying to help by pushing off his
shoulders and then you could see his
arms bent there his arms bent she's
trying to push her legs are been they're
just trying to figure it out and her
crotches in his face he definitely
should have strained his arms with that
lip from dirty dancing
as soon as she gets to him he
straightens his arms his arms are locked
she's super tight and it's just such a
cool picture so it's like everyone that
is not a dancer and wants to be lifted
thinks it's super easy I'm sure my first
up was horrible but I never dropped
anyone I'm not going with I much rather
prefer to do the lifting like when I
want to or think and we're always
partnering I just feel so much safer
with us knowing that I'm lifting and
that I can take charge and make it
happen as opposed to trusting someone
else to make
and they trust me too and that's a lot
of pressure but I like it yeah this next
one Chicago who doesn't know Chicago
let's play this way
[Music]
this is so good like you would think she
was a dancer her intensity in this and
her focus like she's doing this like a
real dancer like you wouldn't know that
this is an actress
dancing to me I think she fits in so
well with the dances and she looks like
she is part of this tango and part of
this scene which is why I think this
goes over so well because she just looks
like a natural this is like actually a
tango how impressive is that even her
she's in the middle with all them in her
splits I like with musicals also it's
you add that extra element you're not
just dancing you have to sing the entire
time and a lot of times you sing out
loud because when you live saying it
looks like it on camera so it's a lot of
times you're singing out loud you have
the enunciate especially in musicals in
a movie you want to get the words across
and you want to get all the musical
right and they all sing in different
parts and they're in heels and they're
on the ground
and they're not wearing kneepads a lot
of times too as dancers and as guys when
you're covered you get to wear kneepads
which is a good secret to like protect
yourself but yet when you're in lingerie
like this and like not wearing much you
can't put a knee pad on you know unless
you're doing an eighties movie and it
works I have had some bad costume
experiences I mean shoes are a big thing
because all the surfaces that you dance
on are different a lot of times it's
when they want you in a dress you and
they want you to dance it's like you're
dancing on ice one of the tricks is
you'll get like coca-cola and you'll
have it on the side on a towel and you
kind of try to make your shoes as sticky
as possible that doesn't work use
hairspray if that doesn't help you can
get like a rubber on the bottom of it so
there's a lot of tricks to make your
shoes danceable for you a lot of times
they have to make a lot of adjustments
step up to the streets
[Applause]
dancing in that rain also already
applaud them for this without even
finishing the rest of the clip like
that's not easy water changes everything
I mean trying not to slip and having
this in your eye and it's coming down on
you the whole time
ringing is not fun it looks cool it
always looks really cool but it's never
fun after the second or third day it's
like the crews nice to you and the
director is nice and they have thought
to warm the water first because a lot of
times I've done something where the
waters not warm
so like you'll be doing this and you
have to pretend like it's fine but
you're like freezing
it's very dangerous and very hard
because they're really close to each
other - and now they're breakdancing and
their legs are going everywhere they're
turning over I mean I can not tell you
how many times I've gotten like kicked
or hit in the head or the face or the
body anywhere just cause it's like you
can't really see what you're doing with
stuff like this and a lot of times
you're blind like you have a blind spot
and it just comes with the territory
and they're on the ground with the water
in their face I'm sure they can't see
anything
they're just relying alike their spatial
awareness and their muscle memory to
like do what they know how to do
[Music]
cause that rewind this that was cool
1 2 3 4 4 nice pins so this is not a
nice pins not easy to do in general even
doing one he just sit for like I'm sure
he's wearing knee pads under those jeans
because that would just kill your knees
you're literally turning on your kneecap
that's it's called a nice spinning like
that's what you're doing you're turning
on your knees yeah
that was dope he's killing it he is
killing it he's giving you like
old-school Michael vibes right like with
the footwork and the hat yeah I thought
that that's another thing about these
dance movie that also are not realistic
it's like they always have the crowd and
a perfect square watching and no one
comes in I mean when have you gone out
and seen like everyone perfect square
watching something anything at that
matter like not even dancing despite the
water and everything else they're
working against they are killing it I
give this scene an a because they're so
together they're doing really hard moves
and they look good doing it this next
one's climax I haven't seen this one yet
[Music]
that kids amazing I have no idea what
he's doing and there's no I don't even
know what style this is but it's amazing
it looks like a mixture of like what
bone breakers do bone breaking is like
they do all that stuff with the
shoulders in their arms and they keep
their hands connected which he's doing a
little bit of I'm sure this was
choreographed I'm sure if not
choreographed it was a thought-out
freestyle where he probably wanted to do
the same thing every time for movies at
least a lot of times with movies they
have a special move in mind they want
you to do the same thing so a lot of
times it's choreographed and you'll have
a little bit of freedom there's so much
going on in this scene I like the
combination of the different styles of
everything in this it's like she was
kind of krumping and then she kind of
was doing contemporary it's like a
little bit of everything with this same
thing one take it's really hard because
it's like you can get to 3/4 of it right
some of my stuff you have to start from
the beginning or else you can't use that
tape and then also the aspect is where
the steady camera the cameraman is also
becoming a dancer for this because he
has to be aware of where all the dancers
are where everyone's moving the dancers
have to be aware of the camera and it's
just all married in a way where it can
be seamless and part of the choreography
it's it's really nice when you get a
good Steadicam operator because they
know it and they like come in the room
and they're like a dancer and they'll
watch it and they'll like okay I saw
that person there I know I need to do
this I'll go that way and in this scene
you have to know four guys if the
cameras coming to you you sometimes you
have to break out of choreography let
them pass and then get back into it so
it doesn't look like you ever moved from
your spot which is a really hard thing
to do for some people I honestly didn't
know what to expect when this clip
started and I'm really into this I think
a lot of times dancing movies it's like
the storyline that kills it right it's
like it's just always so cheesy when
it's like a movie and it's like I save
the last dance or something you're like
okay this is realistic the Dancing's not
that great like why are you doing that
let's make this person take a class and
then she falls in love with this hip-hop
dancer and then now they're gonna be
together and now she knows how to do
everything and it's real
I love seeing dance of all forms in all
movies and it doesn't have to be
necessarily like technically correct
it's like we saw silver linings playbook
where they're just having fun and it's
like you want to see that it makes it
relatable you see these movies and it
like makes you want to get up and dance
with them I mean who doesn't love to
dance and music brings everyone together
and it's great seeing it on film